In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for September 18th, on which we commemorate, our Holy
Father Evmenios the Wonderworker, Bishop of Gortina, in Crete.
From his early years, Saint Evmenios gave himself over entirely to a life of austereas geese
and extreme renunciation that he fittingly combined with deep humility.
His countenance was always bathed in tears, and no one ever heard him find fault with anyone
or give so much as a hearing to gossip.
Seeing that he fulfilled all righteousness, the people of Gortina constrained him to become
their bishop.
He accomplished everything that belongs to that office wisely, in all things obedient
to the Holy Spirit, and working many miracles by his prayers.
Yielding to the divine will, he illumined Rome with godly teaching and miracles.
He then journeyed to the Thabayid, where without intending a miracle, he put an end to a time
of drought by his prayer.
It was in the Thabayid that he fell asleep in the Lord, and the faithful who dwelt there,
sent his holy body to be buried in Raxles in his homeland, where the body of his predecessor
St. Cyril already lay.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.